when Stormtroopers captured a reporter
this morning very nice a bunch of
celebrities like us Stormtroopers icon
IC
Stormtrooper one of the most iconic
symbols of Star Wars and the Galactic
Empire but where did they come from and
how did they evolve into the emperor's
personal enforcers in this video we'll
take a closer look at the history and
evolution of Stormtroopers from the Old
Republic all the way to the first order
the origins of the Stormtrooper can be
traced back to the Old Republic a few
thousand years before the events of the
Star Wars films at the time the old
Republic's military was made up of
Republic Troopers whose training and
armor was based on the mandalorians who
they had been at war with several times
These Old Republic Troopers had many
similarities to mandalorians including
the recognizable t-shaped helmet and
full body armor this armor was later
adapted by the kaminoans for their Clone
Trooper Army several thousand years
later in the film attack of the Clones
we get to see the earliest iteration of
the Stormtrooper in Clone Troopers these
clones were created to serve as the army
of the galactic Republic and were
genetically engineered to be obedient
soldiers loyal to the Jedi Order they
were also cloned from a Mandalorian
named Jango Fett further connecting the
design of the Stormtrooper to the
Mandalorian people just as the Old
Republic armor was modeled after
Mandalorian armor created by Kim and
Owen armorsmiths for the clone troopers
of the galactic Republic the phase one
clone trooper armor consisted of 20
form-fitting plates of lightweight
plastoid alloy composite those plates
were sealed to a black temperature
controlled bodysuit which was
pressurized offering temporary
protection against the vacuum of space
in this era the armor carried different
color combinations to denote different
ranks and squads The Phase 1 colorful
armor was later replaced with the more
iconic black and white armor this Phase
2 Armor was adopted by nearly all cloned
soldiers of the galactic Republic by the
final days of the Clone Wars this
updated armor was better suited for the
human anatomy as the original Phase 1
armor was designed by the kaminoans The
Phase 2 Armor was better fit for the
clones and since all the armor was
basically identical the Clones began
using splashes of color and unique armor
customizations to denote their
individuality and personality while the
clone troopers of the galactic Republic
were the first generation of the Empire
Stormtroopers TK Troopers represented
the rise of human recruits instead of
relying on cloning they were trained by
clone commandos as part of project
Warman and where a prototype armor which
was based on the phase 2 clone trooper
armor this first version of the
Stormtrooper was called the TK trooper
and it's only had a few on-screen
appearances such as in the Animated
Series the bad batch this TK Trooper
design is actually the same as Ralph
mcquarie's original design for the
Stormtrooper before it was changed later
in the production process the TK armor
was more streamlined than the clone
trooper armor and had a sleeker more
menacing look however it had several
design flaws including poor ventilation
and limited Mobility to address these
issues the Empire finally developed
stormtrooper armor as is most popular
today this armor featured improved
ventilation and mobility and it provided
additional protection for the wearer the
stormtrooper armor also included a
built-in comlink and a respiratory
system that filtered out harmful toxins
the term Stormtrooper actually comes
from a particular group of Troopers
during World War One these Troopers
specialized in storming trenches and
often wore gas masks that could filter
out toxins just as the Stormtroopers
from Star Wars wear despite their
reputation for being inaccurate and
easily defeated by the rebel alliance
Stormtroopers were some of the deadliest
fighters in the Galaxy also the Empire
continued to develop new technologies
and specialized units to improve the
Stormtroopers capabilities one example
was the creation of Scout Troopers who
were trained for reconnaissance and
deployed in forests and other wooded
areas another example was the creation
of the snow troopers who were trained to
operate in harsh environments like the
ice Planet Hoth in addition to their
specialized units the Empire also
experimented with new technologies to
enhance the Stormtroopers combat
abilities one notable example was the
shadow Troopers who were equipped with
cloaking devices that made them nearly
invisible on the battlefield another
example was dark Troopers who were
advanced battle droids that were used to
attack rebel bases and fortifications
the list doesn't stop there though the
empire built up a collection of
specialized forces including sand
troopers shock troopers death Troopers
Shore Troopers Patrol Troopers mud
Troopers space Troopers heavy Troopers
and more following the fall of the
Galactic Empire a number of Imperial
loyalists formed the Imperial Remnant a
group that sought to restore the empire
to power many Stormtrooper remained
loyal to the Empire and joined this
Remnant these Stormtroopers continued to
wear the classic white armor but they
often had modifications or personalized
touches that set them apart from the
original design they were involved in a
number of conflicts with the new
Republic and some even joined the first
order when it emerged years later we can
see these Stormtroopers in titles such
as the Mandalorian working under the
warlord moth Gideon during this time we
see the rise of the new Republic as well
as another group that would adopt a
stormtrooper once again after the fall
of the Empire the remnants of the
Imperial Army regrouped and formed the
first order the first order
Stormtroopers were trained from birth
and taken from their families to instill
loyalty in the first order they were
trained to be more efficient and
ruthless than their predecessors and
were equipped with updated armor and
weapons the first order stormtrooper
armor was similar in design to the
original stormtrooper armor but with
several improvements darmer featured
better ventilation and Mobility as well
as a helmet that provided better
visibility and protection the armor also
included a blaster resistant shield and
a built-in energy projector that could
deflect Blaster bolts the first order
also equipped our Storm Troopers with a
new weapon the f11d Blaster rifle which
was more accurate and had a longer range
than the E11 Blaster rifle used by the
original Stormtroopers the first order
also developed specialized units for
specific emissions just as the empire
did for example flame troopers were
equipped with incendiary weapons that
could cause devastating damage to enemy
positions the riot control Stormtroopers
had specialized riot shields and stun
batons which they used to maintain order
and quell uprisings other specialized
troops included snow troopers
executioner Troopers jet Troopers scuba
Troopers and More in early drafts of
Star Wars and Ralph macquarie's Concept
Designs Stormtroopers were to wield
lightsabers and handheld Shields as
common weapons rather than just the Jedi
when composing additional background
information though George Lucas changed
these details and developed the more
classic Stormtrooper design we know
today ever since the Stormtrooper has
been an iconic symbol of the Star Wars
franchise the evolution of the
Stormtrooper from the clone troopers of
the Clone Wars to the elite soldiers of
the first order is a testament to the
creativity and Imagination of the star
Sports creators Stormtroopers continue
to be a formidable force in the Star
Wars universe and will undoubtedly
remain a beloved part of the franchise
for years to come subscribe for more
Star Wars content and if you like the
video check out this one too